особисто давно попереджав єдине що я
звичайно не був готовий до такого
масштаба навіть я поїхав до військкомату
оцінив обстановку побачив що напад іде
одразу з багатьох напрямків є Що скоріше
за все Запоріжжі буде спроба штурм це
вже було зрозуміло на другий третій день
тому ми при військкоматі була
організована група швидкого реагування
Ми почали готуватися зустрічати росіян
на
південному напрямку їздив в Запоріжжя
а-а чи була готова країна Ну як бачимо
ні звичайно це буде на майбутнє велика
розмова про причини того що сталося чи
можна було цього уникнути Я зараз як
діючий військовослужбовець не можу
казати Казати багато речей Але прийде
час і будуть задані дуже неприємні
питання для Багато кого ми будемо
вимагати відповідей